[Music]
so what was the prime minister like
back in the days when he was a fierce
advocate for liberty i'm joined now by
patronella wyatt who worked at the
spectator when boris johnson was editor
and who knows his character well
patronella thanks for joining us today
fraser wonders in his cover piece
whether the pm has
lost his liberalism do you think he has
yes i do i think the problem with boris
is that
um not that he doesn't have a series of
beliefs
because he does and they are
instinctively liberal
but they're not deeply held enough
they're not so
deeply held that they can't be
sacrificed to what he sees as
political expediency and the continuing
prosperity of boris johnson i think
unfortunately his greatest belief
is in himself so he's
not a conviction politician
and he's very much an opinion
poll sort of prime minister
and he yo-yos all over the place because
he thinks
this is what please this is what is
going to please people
um and i think that's a terrible
weakness in a prime minister because you
have to have a consistent
policy you have to have the moral
courage to
stand up for what you believe in but i i
don't think going back to his beliefs
yes he has a history of expanding
liberal beliefs but i don't think
his beliefs are terribly profound i
don't think he's a terribly profound
person and yet he's spoken
with such a fierce passion and defense
of liberty in the past i mean he used to
rail
against things like id cards which is
now
seems like a much lighter policy
compared to a vaccine passport
he said in the telegraph in 2004 that if
an official ever was asked to see
an id card he would take it out of his
wallet and physically
eat it you are suggesting though that
even putting forward those robust
defenses of liberalism
the polls now matter more to him
yes um but also remember that he was
put for he put forth these views in
articles
um and his articles are always very
entertaining
and there was always an element of
exaggeration
he would not have actually eaten his id
card
i honestly can't see him doing that
boris is a performer
and performers will exaggerate
and performers are more interested in
the performance
than in in beliefs
because honestly if his liberal beliefs
were so
strongly held he wouldn't be doing this
he he would not be thinking about
backs and passports which is so coercive
he wouldn't be saying to businesses and
offices
well um you don't have to wear a mask
but if you don't we will force you to
i mean he's not acting like a liberal
conservative
why isn't he because his liberal
conservatives beliefs
aren't that strong and his desire to
stay in power is stronger
of course that masked mandate is lifting
although the pm's
talk in recent days has been extremely
cautious and they seem to have done
quite a few uh u-terms at least in terms
of the rhetoric
about how they're going to treat freedom
day pacinelli you knew boris johnson
when he worked at the spectator
what was he like then um
he was a very genial person
but you would notice that he would say
different things to different people
make them different promises
um because he's a people pleaser
and that will get him into a lot of
trouble and in the end
you end up pleasing nobody and this is
what he's been like
as a politician he sees opinion polls
which
may or may not be accurate claiming that
a significant number of people
want to keep going with the restrictions
but some of these polls are dubious like
the ipsos maury because the ft
took it apart um and
and this is why he he sort of does this
um but it's not it's not a sustainable
policy
because it's not leadership um i mean
going back to
his personality at the spectator
um he did have a tendency when it came
to
politics to agree with
one person on the right and then 10
minutes later
in another room agree with one person on
the left
and that's just boris because boris
wants to be liked
but it's not a great trait in a
in a leader especially during a crisis
um are we getting to the crux of it in
the sense that boris johnson really
supports liberalism in the sense that he
likes to be able to do what he wants
and but then when it comes to something
like a national emergency where the
government has you know
huge amounts of power over our lives
he's still quite
he quite likes to be able to to do what
he wants the problem is that we all have
to follow along with it too
yes i would say that's a pretty good
summation
um he wants to do what he wants um
so he will not observe social distancing
and when we saw that at wembley we saw
that
at the g7 summit um but
he will force the rest of us to do it
um and you get a you've got to bury them
enough
situation with this government and
that that is very dangerous for a
politician that could come back to bite
him because he's now
very he's annoying his call base
immensely uh because i speak to mps who
are getting emails from their
constituents all the time
saying what's going on this is not a
conservative government
this is a kind of socialist status
government
and it's already well for boris to do
what he
wants in number 10 and go to parties
which they all do and and not wear masks
but um you cannot flaunt this as he does
in photo opportunities and then
you know expect the british people
to to mask up well
last question petronella if another
prime minister
were in his place and boris were still
writing his columns
what do you think he'd be saying about
the current restrictions and freedom day
on the 19th of july
oh yeah he'd be um he'd be saying that
the current restrictions were appalling
infringement of freedom
he'd be crazing pericles of athens he'd
be quoting benjamin franklin
um he'd be pouring scorn on
himself as it were um i mean if he was
still the old
boris um because i i think the
old boris has sort of disappeared power
has done something to him
um he would be hating himself as prime
minister
petronella thanks for joining us on
spectator tv
[Music]
you